ladies and recommended support equipment
final President of the United States
[Applause]
okay okay relax relax I get it
we're all very excited about the new
Senate health care bill it's a mean
beautiful heartless amazing Travis tree
of an accomplishment that I'm told I
support sure
I support it cuts taxes for the rich and
reduces coverage for everyone else I
call it the reverse Obama care which is
also a fantastic sexual position where
the man gets on top and screws a bunch
of poor people today you tweeted that
there are no tapes of your conversations
with coaming there are absolutely no
recordings of my conversations in the
White House then why did you suggest
that their work tape didn't you hear me
play it back there are absolutely no
recording of my conversation in the one
scene this is a total witch hunt we look
at this guy's got a pitchfork
it's a pattern it could be a tawny
pitchfork I can't risk it bring it in
boys are you serious no surprise eaters
now I'm right every right okay I got
your letter I'm letting you film this
that's so much better
I got that straight from the Department
of Defense thank you thank you so much
oh thank you thank you for me
thank you so are you or are you not
under investigation yes yes to which
you're not the witch you're the witch
which is why tonight's theme is witch
hunt
that's all this Russian thing is witch
hunt should be reserved for black
presidents who weren't born here and
crooked old ladies who bleach their
emails I'm bewitched bothered and
bewildered and I'm the president can you
believe it
what's wrong
[Applause]